many people use Thanksgiving as an
opportunity to volunteer and give back
to their communities but for one
Louisiana woman every day is a reason to
help out
Alma Johnson is known as the
neighborhood nanny she offers support to
any parent in need by caring and cooking
for their children at no cost
Michelle Miller met Johnson to learn
what inspired her spirit of giving back
[Music]
Alma Johnson starts every day minding a
huge pot over a firey stove it's like
you're cooking for an army now I've been
doing this for so long
I love it she runs what's become an
unofficial daycare for a community in
desperate need of a caring hand but she
never really I do not let it run I can't
let it run for as long as this
grandmother can remember
she's been caring for dozens of her
littlest neighbors in Crowley Louisiana
my house is never empty double seven
days a week always have some kids you
how do you do it
I just love because I I made a promise
to the Lord and he gave me this pen to
do it that strength is helping mother
natalie goth me and I didn't have no
babysitter no money no nothing
she started bringing her sons here after
leaving an abusive relationship she
couldn't afford child care you know be a
babysitter a week is 250 200 they cannot
afford it because they got to pay the
bills these are working people need work
and if they don't go to work you know
their kid wouldn't have no room for a
soul all right miss Alma doesn't charge
for her services parents pitching that
they can for food toilet paper and
diapers she also sets the example for us
as parents as to go out there and do
something go to school if you're at
school go to work if you need to work I
got that you don't worry about and
they're saying
you don't have a lot here no ma'am I
would love I have a lot of love and a
lot of tension but pastor Warren Nelson
knows she's more than that
this is a travesty that many children in
our community and in our country are in
need of food supplies and clothing since
the ELMO takes the little that she has
and causes it to become much in the
lives of children and her charges are
learning firsthand the value of getting
back what you get for CBS this morning
Michelle Miller Crowley Louisiana I love
this story cooking for people is the
surest most easy way to show them that
you love them in the air character and
you think about the impact she's had on
so many families yeah she really is
family for all of them at that America
we have more of that yes we do